a new timeline brings some new
challenges old faces and even some
theoretical astrophysics to the umbrella
academy season 3. but what clues can we
discover in the new trailer let's find
out
the whole series so far essentially
revolves around the fact that victor
hargreaves played by eliot page has the
devastating ability to turn sound waves
into energy capable of destroying the
entire planet also known as the white
violin victor's apocalyptic powers are
the reason the team had to flee to the
1960s at the end of season one and they
start to cause havoc again in season two
but the new trailer suggests that victor
has a better grip on them enough to team
up with lila pitts what's interesting is
the fact that lila is once again using
her mimicking abilities to copy the
white violins skills remember she first
used this victor's energy against the
team in the battle at the end of season
two but the two characters are seemingly
working together in the fresh footage
this would be interesting to see how
that dynamic changes things for the gang
in this new universe there's also a
blink in your mist appearance of the
hotel obsidian with a huge neon sign
that sits on top of a building this
might look a little familiar to fans of
the comic series that the show is based
on in the comics reginald hargreaves
creates a hotel oblivion as a prison to
house all the villains that the academy
has faced over the years unfortunately
he created it outside of reality in its
own dimension which makes for a pretty
grim existence for the hotel's prisoners
they're guarded by a doctor
manhattan-like figure called the
scientific man and he eventually fights
a number of bad guys when they break out
of the hotel so what does this all mean
for the netflix show well it looks like
the obsidian is a different version of
the oblivion in this new alternate
timeline but we'll just have to wait and
see what secrets it holds in this new
version
after meddling with the timeline in the
past and present for the last two
seasons you'd think the nameless five
has earned some time to kick back and
relax a little of course he could if he
was in the right reality after figuring
out what kind of mess he and his
siblings have wandered into this time it
looks like the time-traveling rebel of
the family is finally giving up his old
threads and trying something new on
precise in the new trailer a brief
moment shows five looking more like a
private investigator than a member of
the umbrella academy chances are that
after the first encounter with the
sparrows he and the rest of the
umbrellas are in the wind trying to keep
off the sparrow's radar might he be
ditching his classic score uniform to
keep a low profile or is five finally
making a change for the better
near the end of the trailer pogo the
chimpanzee makes a brief appearance when
last we saw pogo he was dead impaled on
a set of antlers hanging on the umbrella
academy parlour wall the new timeline
the trailer introduces makes his return
possible but it remains to be seen how
he is brought back into the lives of the
umbrella academy students his return is
clearly meant to be the promo's big
reveal with just a quick shot of klaus
offering a spoiler alert between pogo's
appearance and the end of the trailer
also back from the dead is ben
hargreaves although he is now part of
the rival sparrow academy this is the
umbrella academy wrong again
this
is the sparrow academy
the trailer picks up where season 2
ended with the umbrella academy siblings
jumping safely back from 1964 to 2019 to
discover that ben and their father
reginald are alive again and the sparrow
academy has replaced them in their home
after the sparrow academy students are
introduced we mostly see them fighting
with their umbrella academy counterparts
one character pursues the umbrella
academy team through a hallway with the
help of an army of conjured crows and
there are several quick flashes of
punches and kicks being thrown between
students of the two academies ben who
appears to be the leader of the sparrow
side unleashes tentacles from his chest
that reach from the academy parlor floor
to the balcony above so his powers at
least appear to be the same in this
universe whether they remain in conflict
with the umbrella academy crew or
eventually join them is unclear but the
sparrow academy team is clearly a huge
part of the umbrella academy season 3.
if one thing stands out in this trailer
it's a repetition of one word google
blitz what the hell is a cougar blitz
well it sounds like hand wavy sci-fi
technobabble a kugelblitz is a real
thing actually just ask your local
theoretical astrophysicist or you know
we could just ask five when we jumped
here we created a time paradox our
little paradox brought forth the
freaking kugelblitz
according to futurism a cougar bled says
german for ball lightning and is formed
when a massive amount of energy is
focused and concentrated on a single
point in space this focus causes both
time and space to warp around the highly
energized points forming an event
horizon beyond which nothing is
observable the phenomenon is similar to
a black hole and a prediction of general
relativity necessitated by the
prevailing theory's mass energy
equivalents in other words the
concentration of energy should form a
singularity in the same way a collapsing
star would in the season 3 trailer for
the umbrella academy the kugel blitz has
shown radiating waves of energy which
appear to cause things in their growing
radius to turn to ash and disappear it's
all a lot to take in so we recommend at
the very least to survey course in
astrophysics before you dive into season
3 when it premieres on june 22nd check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite television shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]